From Wes Anderson's intern, to painter,
to chipmunk? Matthew Gray Gubler has
been Hollywood's quirkiest star even
before Criminal Minds. Here's a look into
his early days, first role, and beyond.
Though Matthew Gray Gubler is
known as a successful actor,
he didn't always think of acting as a career.
According to Biography, Gubler studied acting
while in high school at the Las Vegas Academy
of Arts because his main interest, filmmaking,
wasn't an option. Fortunately for
him, he was naturally talented,
and he went on to star in multiple
productions while in school. Gubler said,
"I never thought I'd be making a living
off of acting — it's still kind of a
shock for my family and friends to see
my face on TV every Wednesday night."
He eventually graduated from New York
University's Tisch School of the Arts
with a degree in film directing, and later
got the opportunity to direct 11 episodes
of "Criminal Minds." Fellow Las Vegas natives
and mega music stars The Killers hired Gubler
to direct two of their music videos as well. The
actor helmed The Killers' videos "Don't Shoot Me
Santa" and "Dirt Sledding." When his breakout
show was reaching its final episode, Parade
asked if Gubler was going to continue acting
or go back to directing, to which he replied,
"With everything I've done in every way, I've
always tried to not necessarily give myself
a limit or a trajectory, which is how I was
fortunate enough to end up on this TV show. So,
I think for the future, while directing
is still one of my biggest passions,
everything is my passion, so I
would love to continue acting."
Before he landed his big role on "Criminal
Minds," Matthew Gray Gubler was a successful
male model. While still a student in New
York, he was stopped by a model scout with
DNA Model Management and was soon modeling
for industry giants like Tommy Hilfiger,
Marc Jacobs, and American Eagle, according to TV
Guide. Regarding the whole experience, he joked,
"It was during a time when there were
really emaciated weirdos modeling. It
wasn't like they were looking for Fabio."
Even though he's been characteristically
self-deprecating about his looks, Gubler was
a successful model who walked in fashion shows and
appeared in several print campaigns. According to
models.com, he was once ranked in the top 50 male
models, holding the 46th spot. While he's often
recognized for his looks, Gubler has confessed
that he was bullied as a kid. He told Glamour,
"I'm so thankful for every bully I've ever
had. It never affected me, and that's why
I'm so thankful for them. I learned early on
that if anything, it made me stick closer to
who I am and not try...it just made me very
solid with who I was. I don't see it like,
'poor me.' I was lucky. It taught me a beautiful
lesson, and I'm really grateful for it."
"All we want in life is for someone
to see us for who we really are."
Matthew Gray Gubler's first acting credit is
all thanks to Wes Anderson. In an interview
with Glamour, Gubler explained how he came to
meet Anderson through an internship. He shared,
"In order to graduate from film school, we
had to do a semester of interning. I really
wanted to intern for Wes because he's one of my
favorite filmmakers and lives in New York and has
a production company there. I sent a little weird
DVD of movies I made and a note saying I would
love to get him coffee. I lucked out and got to
work there, and that was a real dream come true."
During his internship, Anderson convinced
Gubler to audition for his upcoming movie
"The Life Aquatic with Steve Zissou,"
where he ironically played the part
of Intern #1. Shortly after landing
the role, he took a trip to Hollywood
and auditioned for a certain crime
procedural show. The rest is history.
Aside from his passions of acting and filmmaking,
Matthew Gray Gubler is a talented artist. In 2004,
he created a website that featured
his characteristically quirky art
and for years it served as a sort of
art portfolio for his watercolor, oil,
and pastel paintings. He took the webpage down
after Flash was removed from the internet,
but he's since revitalized
his website with a new look.
Gubler's art has appeared
in galleries, group shows,
and magazines, according to The
Things. However, he has confessed
he gets nervous when people critique his
art in person. In 2013, he told Buzzfeed,
"On the internet, it's this safe space where I
can put it up and people can click on it or not.
I don't have to be in the same room as them
pretending to like it, so I very rarely show
people things ... some people misinterpret
my style of painting as offensive, and I've
had instances where I've painted beautiful
portraits for, like, a girlfriend or someone,
and they're just like, they look at it with a
grimace and they're like, 'This is terrible.'"
Despite his insecurities, his pieces
have sold for thousands of dollars,
inspired countless tattoos, and received
praise all across the internet. Gubler
may be modest about his skill, but at least the
rest of the world recognizes his many talents.
In 2007, Matthew Gray Gubler took a reprieve
from the dark world of "Criminal Minds" to
provide the voice of Simon –- the loveable,
nerdy brother of Alvin –- in the feature film
version of "Alvin and the Chipmunks." According
to Box Office Mojo, the movie would go on to earn
an impressive $365 million at the global box
office. Distributed by 20th Century Fox and
helmed by "Muppets from Space" director Tim Hill,
"Alvin and the Chipmunks" combines live action
and computer-generated animation to bring the
beloved 1980s cartoon to life. The story centers
on three chipmunk brothers adopted by human
songwriter Dave Seville. Gubler's character,
Simon, is often the voice of reason among
his mischievous brothers Alvin and Theodore.
"I feel like I'm living in a dumpster."
The actor continued to voice Simon
through three more "Chipmunks" films:
"The Squeakquel," "Chipwrecked," and "The
Road Chip." The sequel earned even more
than its predecessor, raking in $443
million, per Box Office Mojo. However,
the third and fourth films didn't fare quite as
well and there's no word on a fifth movie. In
an interview with Page Six, Gubler reflected
on how much he loved playing Simon. He said,
"Oddly, I feel more a part of this than anything
else I've been lucky enough to be in [...] Actors
talk about dreaming of playing Othello, but for
me, it's Simon. It's the biggest deal to me."
When "500 Days of Summer" was released in 2009, it
stood apart from its romantic-comedy counterparts,
specifically because the romance at
the center of the film doesn't last.
The film centers on 20-somethings Tom and
Summer as they fall in and out of love.
Matthew Gray Gubler co-stars in
the film as Tom's friend, Paul,
who is in a healthy relationship with
a girl named Robyn. He speaks the truth
about real love to Tom and comforts
his friend after Summer dumps him.
"But truthfully, Robyn is better than
the girl of my dreams ... She's real."
Although Gubler only appears in a few scenes,
Paul's perspective on love helps illustrate
how unrealistic Tom is about romance. In an
article about the film's 10th anniversary,
The Observer noted the one-dimensional
characterization of Summer and said of the movie,
"For a film that was heralded as a quirky response
to the traditional romance and has since endured
as a cult classic, its central message and
themes don't go down quite as easily today."
The article further broke down Summer's
lack of character depth and decried her
existence as serving no purpose
aside from Tom's dreams. However,
this is the important truth Gubler's
character subtly points out in the film.
The extremely dark 2008 comedy "How to Be
a Serial Killer" allows Matthew Gray Gubler
to portray a wannabe murderer rather
than a profiler and hunter of serial
killers. Gubler plays Bart — a nebbish video
store clerk who becomes a student of Mike,
a self-help bro with 10 easy steps
to self-actualization via grisly
murder. Mike is a dark, twisted Mr. Miyagi to
Bart's Daniel LaRusso and Gubler plays Bart
with believable cowardice. As a review of the
film from horror website Dread Central notes,
"Bart's the kind of character most
audience members will want to beat
with a sock full of quarters until he
stops being such a simpering idiot."
An independent film, "How to Be a Serial
Killer" was distributed by Monterey Media
and only opened on one domestic theater
screen. According to Box Office Mojo,
the movie played for one weekend and earned $899.
Limited audience reviews of the film on Rotten
Tomatoes were less than favorable. However, Liz,
a super reviewer on the site, called the movie,
"An entertaining social etiquette
of sorts that makes you laugh,
creeps you out and makes you want to become
best friends with Matthew Gray Gubler."
Matthew Gray Gubler doesn't usually live his
romances in the limelight. The actor's love
life isn't the focus of his interviews or press
junkets. Nonetheless, like many other Hollywood
celebrities, he is rumored to have dated Taylor
Swift, per Cosmopolitan. However, Gubler has never
spoken on the record about a former relationship
with the mega pop star. Kat Dennings remains the
one celebrity Gubler has confirmed dating and over
the years, the two have worked on-screen together.
Dennings and Gubler hooked up in 2007
and although their romance didn't last,
their friendship has continued in the years
since. The two appeared together in both the
small independent horror-comedy "Suburban
Gothic" and the short-lived Hulu series,
"Dollface." Gubler sat down
with the website Shock Ya to
discuss "Suburban Gothic" and his
relationship with Dennings, saying,
"I love Kat, as she's actually
one of my closest friends,
and we actually dated many years ago. It's very
rare to find weirdos who are like yourself,
so when you find them, you keep them close."
The imaginative comedy series "Dollface"
ran for two seasons on Hulu. The show
centered on Dennings character, web
designer Jules Wiley and her search
for love and purpose. Gubler co-starred
as Wes, Jules' potential love interest.
After Matthew Gray Gubler began to gain
public recognition for his role as Dr.
Spencer Reid in "Criminal Minds," he poked
fun at his newfound celebrity status. In 2006,
Gubler launched a YouTube series called "Matthew
Gray Gubler: The Unauthorized Documentary" – an
obviously satirical episodic series. The actor's
humorous commentary on narcissistic celebrities
who take themselves too seriously pre-dates
the similarly themed Joaquin Phoenix vehicle
"I'm Still Here." Although both parodies mock
celebrity culture, Phoenix did extensive press for
"I'm Still Here" in character. Phoenix infamously
appeared as his self-absorbed character on "The
Late Show with David Letterman" which prompted the
actor to apologize to Letterman 18 months later.
"But I apologize. I hope I
didn't offend you in any way."
"No, no, no."
"I'm Still Here" could almost qualify as serious
performance art, whereas Gubler's video series
delights in its silliness. Gubler's YouTube
series spans 14 short episodes, each episode
running under 10 minutes, throughout two seasons
and features guest appearances. In Season 1,
Episode 11, the late, great Anton Yelchin takes
acting lessons from Gubler. MTV News points out,
"[Gubler] has a wonderful sense of humor
and isn't afraid to make fun of himself."
"If we can't shoot the last scene, they can't
end the show, and I don't want the show to end."
We couldn't agree more. Season 2 of "The
Unauthorized Documentary" aired from 2020 to 2021.
When the "Criminal Minds" reboot
was announced, the show's fans grew
excited at the return of their favorite
FBI profilers. Before "Criminal Minds:
Evolution" premiered, Deadline announced
the return of many long-time stars. However,
glaringly missing from the cast announcement
was Matthew Gray Gubler as Dr. Spencer Reid.
Over 15 seasons, Gubler appeared in 323 of the
original "Criminal Minds" episodes. The actor,
who began his trajectory
on the show when he was 25,
wrapped the series finale when he was
40. Both Gubler and Reid grew up through
the show's lengthy run. In an exclusive
interview with Looper, Gubler's friend
and co-star Paget Brewster opened up about
his absence from the reboot. She explained,
"Matthew was the only person
in the last two seasons that
had been in every single episode.
He did 15 years straight through."
She elaborated on Gubler's choice to
decline reprising his role, adding,
"He was never able to go do
other stuff, so I understand."
However, Gubler's character hasn't
been killed off of "Criminal Minds:
Evolution," and there are numerous
plausible explanations for Reid's
absence. Perhaps Gubler will make
guest appearances in future episodes.